salut vous l'avez compris dans le titre
aujourd'hui je reçois un grand magicien
que j'adore qui s'appelle luc langevin
ill à paris pour quelques jours parce
qu'il est au casino tas en spectacle et
du coup je vais fait venir jusqu'à moi
pour qu'il nous fasse des tours sur la
chaîne avant d'aller à son spectacle en
parlant du spectacle la tournée du mien
de singularité continue je saurai les 25
26 27 et 28 avril au théâtre de la tour
eiffel à paris
et puis bientôt je serai près de reims
près de tours a lyon un peu partout en
fait et puis aussi en belgique en suisse
bref vous avez toutes les villes sur mon
site internet
lien dans la description aller voir les
villes parce que des fois tu dis quand
est-ce que tu passes et je suis déjà
passé
en fait voilà je trouvais ça dommage de
le faire venir uniquement pour nous
faire des tours alors qu'il a un rapport
à la science
tu es très intéressant et on va discuter
de tous à partir de bas de ma faim je
suis très content que tu sois ici avec
nous et surtout je sais qu'il vient à
peine de descendre de l'avion
c'est ça et nous nous on s'est tous
réunis là avec les abonnés en se disant
comme ça on va peut-être pouvoir le
petit orc et des secrets parce qu'il
n'est pas en vigilance mentale extrême
tu vois moi je pourrais me il ya
certaines personnes qui ont des
questions pour toi et moi aussi j'en ai
et puis bah tu réponds aussi librement
que tu veux et tu as le droit tous les
joker que tu veux ok je pose la première
on fait ça c'est beaucoup mieux écoute
moi je connais tout ton parcours au
québec j'avais vu quand elle était venue
en 2016 et 2017 en france avait été un
succès incroyable avec une magie moderne
des choses nouvelles et surtout un
rapport en permanence à la science qui
était très intéressant dans le propos et
ça aussi ça venait de la modernité parce
que il y avait la magie celle qui nous
bluffer mais on sait que la science ça
nous bluffe aussi en permanence et
j'aimerais savoir comment toi tu es
passé de ton rapport à la science ce
rapport à l'illusionnisme en fait mon
premier amour ça a été la magie
l'illusion en fait j'ai d'abord eu un
intérêt pour la magie avant que ce soit
pour la science mais rapidement mais mes
parents m'ont dit que je peux pas gagner
ma vie en fezensac sa part une vraie
profession en bas toi et moi le sais et
je me rendais bien compte qu'il y avait
pas de cours de magie
allez que personne est un diplômé de ça
donc je suis allée dans ce qui pour moi
était le plus proche et moi c'était la
science vraiment que je trouvais qu'il
se rapprochait le plus de la magie je
trouvais que la science et la magie des
temps modernes en fait la science et
explique que le tonnerre c'est explique
le feu ça explique des choses qu'ils
peuvent
avant on disait que c'était de la magie
donc je les étudie la physique plus
précisément parce que je trouvais qu'il
y avait des phénomènes avec le
magnétisme avec la la gravité avec les
lasers des choses qui me semblent très
magique et ça m'intéressait j'avais un
réel intérêt pour la science
et c'est à l'âge de 16 ans où j'ai
commencé à voir qu'en fait que la
majorité des tours de magie que j'avais
appris en fait souvent fonctionné par
des principes scientifiques mais connu
par le grand public et j'ai commencé à
avoir en fait que certains phénomènes
physiques ressemble pratiquement de la
magie que je pouvais faire des tours
simplement en montrant ces phénomènes
aux gens est-ce que tu as toi tu as un
exemple de descente dévoilé vraiment à
tour mais deux des faits scientifiques
qui peut nous illusionner là comme ça
oui mais un des premiers effets que
j'étais c'est l'effet tunnel par exemple
par curiosité est ce que quelqu'un sait
ce que c'est l'effet tunnel
ah oui c'est vrai bon j'avoue moi de
sortir une petite tête de ba oui enfin
désolé j'ai pas gran sasso et qui
connaissent pas qui fait quoi dans la
vie
si bizarre oui donc rien à voir bien une
raison plus d'accord d'accord ça c'est
un phénomène qui est belle en fait c'est
regarder je me déplace sais pas ce que
je vais vous montrer plus que l'essence
de toute son ampleur de ce phénomène en
jouant avec des élastiques en fait parce
que je me suis rendu compte en étudiant
la science que lorsqu'on ce qu'on étire
un élastique en fait on éloigne chacune
des particules qu'il constitue en créant
un vide en chacun des atomes commence à
taper le ski arthur arthur enchanté
arthur
je te prête les deux élastiques
peut-être peuvent être assurés que ce
sont de vrais élastique il se dira qu' à
rien de cacher que c'est qu'on prenne
des élastiques comme on les connaît
c'est bon tout est normal
parfait et comme je le disais lorsqu on
éloigne les particules les unes des
autres on qu'un vidéo facilite l'effet
tunnel
l'effet tunnel c'est un phénomène par
lequel des particules traverse d'autres
particules sans les abîmer en fait
donc vous voyez comme par exemple en ce
moment les élastiques sont vraiment un
derrière le voyez je suis en quelque
sorte mes notes et enlace ticket mais
pas vraiment parce que je peux retenir
mais doit tout moment mais vous
comprenez l'idée que l'élastique faut
pas sortir ni par le centre ni par les
côtés même en tirant n'y a rien à faire
mais regardez juste en frottant
légèrement comme ça tranquillement vous
pouvez voir une branche de l'élastique
traverse puis une deuxième comme par
magie et merci c'est presqu'une la
bienvenue à ce que tu peux me tendre et
et doit comme ça arthur faire deux
crochets oui je plaçais l'un des
élastiques comme celle ci je vais monter
des matches juste comme ça pour que tout
le monde puisse bien voir
je crois que même les incliner un peu
pour la caméra donc et je vais aller de
ton côté comme ça ici donc moi je suis
sûrement ton côté si je tire tout vient
avec est possible de sortir par les
doigts ou encore là par le centre
justin freud on peut voir une branche
c'est une deuxième vie est ici parce que
l'un d'entre vous aurez une bague ou un
jean ou dois je n'ai pas remarqué de la
douane bah oui parce que quelqu'un a un
jeu audois on commence à peine candice
ton 10 et est ce que est ce que la bague
une signification particulière sont
aussi un cadeau d'accord elles ont battu
la wii wii donc si je la bri et c'est
dommage j'en prends note
je vais essayer on va essayer de répéter
l'expérience qu'on a fait avec les
élastiques mans remplaçant 20 des
élastiques par la bac et carla je vais
essayer de le faire pour la caméra en
même temps que le fait pour toi
donc tu vois ta bague soit si je le
cogne contre les l'élastique au compte
de 1 2 3
oui traverse les deux branches de
l'élastique en fait d'un seul coup mais
on peut faire mieux tu peux me tende la
main comme ça je place et celle ci tu
peux fermer tes doigts par dessus la
bague à l'élastique vous les doigts
et voilà elle y reste et je la récupère
c'est vraiment un exemple de deux
phénomènes scientifiques l'effet tunnel
moi qui m'a permis de donner une
crédibilité à 10 tours des tours de
magie ou que qu'ont expliqué pas
vraiment qui était présentée sans
vraiment artifice ou par mois je
trouvais que donnée de parler d'un vrai
phénomène physique parce que ça existe
pour vrai les faits sinon c est ce qui
était intéressant en plus dense que tu
disais à la fin c'est vraiment ça c'est
que là d'un coup au lieu de devoir une
énigme visuel que peut être parfois la
magique c'est que là il ya un espèce de
propos à suspense parce que je suis
intéressé par ce que je vois et parce
qu'ils aient dit donc c'est beaucoup
trop bien mais je reviens aussi sur le
fait que vous aviez peut-être des
questions est ce que quelqu'un une
question c'est quoi ton prénom colline
je me demandais parce que j'imagine que
tu as commencé la magie pour faire rêver
les gens en quelque sorte et je voulais
savoir quelles étaient les réactions que
tu préférais avoir autour c'est à dire
que j'imagine que les personnes qui
disent c'est pas toujours j'aime toutes
les sortes de réactions il y en a
beaucoup et un éventail de réaction très
très large à des gens qui sont
sceptiques justement qui cherche à
comprendre le secret en france beaucoup
comme ça il ya des réactions beaucoup
plus émotive les gens explosif cris et
il ya une fois il ya une personnalité
publique au québec qui s'est mis à
verser des larmes après après un tour
donc il ya vraiment un pilote avait
cassé son téléphone web adjani mais bon
je sais qu aurait misé une émotion parce
que tu as eu des personnes énervé contre
toi oui beaucoup des gens qui m'ont l'as
lens et les accessoires puis en fait
c'est étrangement c'est tout des
réactions que que j'aime parce que ça je
sais qu'il ya que la magie pour faire
vivre des choses comme ça on les
émotions qu'on vit en voyant un tour de
magie mille usions on les vit pas en
voyant un spectacle d'humour ou du
théâtre un peu quand même mais même pas
comme la magie ou en a pour un court
instant l'impression de croire au père
noël comme lorsqu'on était enfin
l'émerveillement sera l'émotion qui est
précieuse là tu tues tu nous a montré
une application en fait possible
théorique et d'un effet réel mais est-ce
que des fois tu t'inspires de peut-être
ce que nous permettra de faire à terme
la science j'espère moi le voyage dans
le temps la téléportation la lecture de
penser on sait pas en fait tout est ce
que va aller la science est ce que ça tu
t'en sers pour toi créée en fait la
réalité de sa alors que c'est pas encore
possible le scientifiquement parlant
oui oui en fait je suis souvent
inspirées par des phénomènes qui ont ce
domaine qui ont une promesse d'une
invention de données d'une exploitation
pas compétente la téléportation ce genre
de choses là je pourrais vous en donner
un exemple
si j'y retourne et là albert einstein
qui est reconnue pour son savoir a
souvent dit que le l'imagination est
plus importante que le savoir est
souvent moi j'essaie justement de mettre
l'imagination coeur de mes numéros qu'on
que les gens imaginent quelque chose et
que ça se concrétise
là on va le faire avec des choses très
minimaliste d'ailleurs si vous venez
voir un spectacle ça ressemble pas à ce
qu'on fait là on est entre nous avec des
objets tout banale des élastiques d'aidé
mais évidemment spectacle j'utilise luc
langevin au casino tarifs à la règle
c'est plus un petit des voilà au
trombone des boutons comment tu
t'appelles quentin quand un parfait
quand j'ai quelques objets ici moment le
cas donc je vois j'ai rajouté celui là
et dans un instant je vais te demandait
d'imaginer quelque chose et on va
essayer de le concrétiser de rendre
cette chose bien réel d'accord parce que
70 des deux mains en face de toi comme
ça parfait et simplement les sourires
mais garder la position des mains toi
juste comme ça oui parfait je vais juste
positionner ça parce que je veux placer
quatre objets dans ta main justice parce
que garder l'autre bien ici parce que je
vais je vais dire fermer dans un instant
donc il ya un dé à jouer je place juste
ici il y à une bague encore une fois
qu'ils étaient tous des objets que tu
pourras examiné après si tu le veux
il ya un trombone jaune que je place
juste là et un bouton quand boutons
noirs
je place jusque là quand tu es si je te
demandais de me nommer ces quatre objets
sans les regarder
3 soit de le faire oui bah si tu es
trombone glouton ben ali des trombones
rouillard n'a qu'un très beau jeu vers
fermeté ma part de se garder les objets
comme ça et quand tu es je te demandais
des petits magie n'est que j'enlève un
objet puis un autre puis un homme et
tout ça tu vas l'imaginer ce sera pas
réel sauf pour le dernier objet le
dernier objet mais on va le faire pour
ouvrir
on commence les prefs imagine toi quand
ac que je prends deux objets notamment
quel objet tu es tu imagines grande où
est l'idiot ouvertement oui sinon ce
serait faux âge pendant thalys com
trombone et le trombone et bagues
imagine je prends le trombone je prends
la bague et j'ai ça dans la main si
maintenant attention tu vas prendre la
décision qui va déterminer son choix
final je trombone et la bague ici lequel
tu veux que j'enlève la veille de
trombone bon j'enlève et trombone
d'accord j'enlève le trombone évidemment
tout ce qu'on vient de faire c'est ces
imaginaires sont encore les quatre
objets probablement dans ta main se
répète j'ai dit que le dernier objet
onfray pauvres est nommé quel objet en
dernier nommé team a nommé le trombone
que j'enlève le trombe
parce que c'est lui que je vais enlever
pour vrai en fait des prêts imagine toi
que je prends le trombone de ta main je
le place dans la mine ici parce que tu
vois trombone quelques peurs que
fouiller à travers les objets il pas
caché en tes doigts ou annuler par
regardant bien des gens qui pleurent
je veux des gens qui plaît pas de larmes
dans brothers croyable c'est génial or
c'était effectivement une très bonne
démonstration pour ça et oui là on a
l'impression que la téléportation existe
en fait peut-être en ait envie de te
brûler pour sorcellerie aussi on sait
c'est pour ça qu'on a appelé ça
d'ailleurs dure un temps la
prestidigitation ça vient de presto
digitaux les doigts rapide c'était juste
pour peu qu utiliser le mot magique qui
était pas bonne presse au moyen-âge quoi
tu voudrais leur dire non mais c'est de
la science et des doigts très agile
c'est pour ça est ce que quelqu'un
d'autre à une question
moi j'ai une question c'est un vrai
parti pris de mêler la science à la
magique parce que généralement un
magicien en fait tu veux pas dévoiler
ses tours et est ce que t'as pas peur
finalement que en mêlant ben science et
magie
les gens comprennent un peu plus
facilement
tu es tour et arrive à trouver
finalement les secrets c'est toujours un
défi en fait dans de révéler assez de
sciences pour que ça soit intéressant
mais pas trop pourquoi justement donner
toutes les clés du numéro et moi je
trouve que d'en révéler un peu je trouve
que ça rend la chose d'intéressant de
saran le numéro crédible parce que je
voulais pas faire de la magie en disant
voilà ferme ta main on met un peu de
poudre magique et
et voilà ces disparus je trouvais qu'il
ya un discours un peu infantilisant là
dedans et moi je voulais m'adresser un
public mature un public adulte est gelée
vraiment que les gens puissent apprécier
justement qu'ils apprennent quelque
chose qu'ils repartent avec autre chose
que l'émerveillement liautaud finalement
voit comme par exemple le numéro avec
les élastiques
je sais que je peux parler de l'effet
tunnel sans s'en griller le numéro 1
entre le savoir comment que le phénomène
existe et savoir comment l'appliquer en
quelque sorte c'est ça se fait pas de
façon façon triviale comme ça tu sais
que moi je suis passionné par les
sciences mais surtout pas le mental est
tout ouïe toutes les sciences cognitives
qu'elle soit physiologiques et
psychologiques toi je sais que dans tes
spectacles déjà tu pratiques du
mentalisme et c'est très intéressante
dans le nouveau simpson j'ai pas encore
mille nouveaux cas est ce que toi dans
ton intérêt on est sûr de la science
physique un peu plus est ce que tu t'es
intéressé aux propriétés fondamentales
du cerveau soit celle qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui de lui soit celle qu'on
continue à découvrir c'est comme
l'univers on découvre encore plein de
possibilités avec le cerveau et si oui
est ce que tu as pu à l'appliquer à des
numéros pareils à des propos est tout à
fait en fait
non seulement l'aspect cognitives du
cerveau est intéressant il ya beaucoup
de facettes au cerveau par exemple la
plupart des gens savent pas mais le
cerveau humain et mais des ombres les
ondes électromagnétiques exactement
comme nos téléphones portables puis un
jour je me suis demandé est-ce qu'on
pourrait capter ces ondes pour
évidemment pour lui lire dans les
pensées des gens avoir une idée de ce
qui se passe à l'intérieur mais au-delà
de ça si si je capte les ondes qu'est-ce
que je peux faire avec pour capter une
onde électromagnétique je me suis rendu
compte ça prend une antenne une antenne
c'est un objet métallique cancans je
réfléchissais à ça j'étais en train de
manger puis y avait il y avait une
fourchette j'ai déjà une fourchette dans
les mains je me suis dit est ce que par
exemple une fourchette métalu quel
hasard incroyable et samassa m'inspire
un numéro que je peux vous présentait
justement journée non mais je peux que
penser que parce que c'est moi qui les
ai apportés qu'elles sont spéciales donc
comment il s'appelle lucas lui car c'est
un très beau non je ne vous ai pas dit
ça les autres assure que ce sont de
vrais fourchette en fait qu'elles sont
parfaitement normal qu'avec elle ne plie
pas facilement que comment bien
important du super tu t'es pas du tout
est bon parfait et je laime tourner vers
comment vous appelez marine ont dû
choisir une fourchette ce que vous
voulez celle ci c'est ma préférée
finistère pouvoir avec je la récupère et
donc on va tenter une expérience de
psycho kinésique y ait la capacité pour
une personne ah si on veut agir à
distance sur les objets uniquement avec
le cerveau uniquement avec les ondes
émises par le cerveau on va le faire
avec la fourchette j'essaie de me placer
pour que tout le monde voit bien si je
secoue légèrement la fourchette comme ça
déjà vous pouvez percevoir qu'il ya
quelque chose qui n'est pas normal
il ya une branche ici qui se dressait
marine peut-être vérifie si c'est
vraiment solide c'est pas deux branches
amovible qui seront je ne sais pas voilà
longtemps que tu confirmes une branche
comme ça c'est bien mais ce qui est
mieux c'est de faire avec la fourchette
ou complet encore là j'essaie de le
faire pour la caméra il pour vous en
même temps oui si je pose mon majeur sur
la fourchette vous allez voir
tranquillement
c'est subtil mais prévoir le manche
le manche sadr et 6,7 des formes en fait
sous l'effet je vais pas vous dire sous
quelle effet parce que là ce serait
aller trop loin justement fait pas ils
ont tous buggé donc voyez si je la
compare avec une autre fourchette qu'on
n'a pas utilisée a quand même quand même
une certaine courbure et battu au revoir
oui quand même qu'avec une différence je
vais le faire à la caméra aussi presque
90 degrés et vous savez parfois il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas impressionnés
par sa parce que les gens savent en
général que si on prendre deux mains et
qu'on force si possible de déformer une
fourchette douce avec la force humaine
on peut le faire mais c'est ce que je
vous propose
on va rester de déformer la fourchette
d'une façon que c'est impossible de le
faire avec les mains ça prendrait une
machine et marine je crois qu'on va le
faire dans tes mains à toi je vais la
remettre bien droite est ce que tu es
gauchère ou droitière droite hier tant
dans sa main droite comme ça je l'a
replacé le plus droit possible c'est le
but que je puisse faire
voilà tu peut refermer tes doigts par
dessus et tourner la maj juste comme ça
parfait si jamais tu juste un peu plus
haute
c'est juste comme ça doit sentir une
légère chaleur commencé la guerre de tam
est marine mais vous ne faites pas c'est
normal
tourner la main et ouvrir les doigts
je sais pas si tu vois la pochette c'est
tordu sur 180° tu peux la prendre et de
payer delà des torts d' si tu veux tu
vas voir que c'est bas c'est
pratiquement impossible en fait ça
prendrait une machine ou une force
surhumaine un sourire d'enfant dray est
ce que tu te la sortie cette tendance
est même arrivé là juste en ontario
sentiments et de tout ça arrive rien des
soins comme ça je te laisser marine mais
je te lavande juste un peu plus je lis
juste comme ça tu vois donc c'est plus
artistique tu feras tu as ostie si tu
manges avec pourquoi pas de crever un
oeil ou quelque chose du genre tu
pourrais regretter le dos voilà sa copie
voilà je regardais les autres comme sa
chose de pourri c'est très
impressionnant et et là on voit en plus
encore à quel point c'est captivant de
t'ecouter en même temps que l'on regarde
ce qui fait qu'on sait jamais d'ailleurs
si on doit regarder ou écouter et je
suis sûr qu'il nous manipule un petit
peu après c'est comme tu disais tout à
l'heure c'est là c'est des petites
choses que nous fait pour illustrer mais
c'est génial parce que quand on se dit
ça c'est des petites choses de luc
langevin donc je n'ose imaginer la forme
qu'à ton nouveau spectacle au casino de
paris du 21 au 31
sinon détendez vous je vous donne ça
assurez vous de ne pas cocher le bouton
à voir la fin et puis ciao
[Musique]
merci beaucoup lui qu encore une fois
d'être venu et merci à vous tous chers
abonnés venu ici pour participer au
tournage
comment ils ont fait eh bien ils ont
regardé longue les communautés en fait
sur ma page youtube et souvent je vous
propose de participer à des tournages
donc répondait comme quoi c'est possible
et la critique on entend souvent c'est
mais pourquoi c'est à paris parce que
jamie la voile à arrêter avec ça je
récupère dans quelques secondes au
bureau si vous êtes intéressés par le
fait d'aller voir luc en spectacle vous
avez son affiche ici les au casino de
paris jusqu'au 31 mai après il va
revenir pour faire une tournée dans
toute la france
et puis vous pouvez aussi venir voir mon
spectacle les 25 26 27 et 28 avril au
théâtre de la tour eiffel en tournée
également les liens vers le spectacle de
luc et vermont spectacle aussi sont dans
la description merci encore à l'udc
d'avoir donné de son temps pour faire
cette vidéo et merci à vous les abonnés
qui est devenu au tournage ça aussi
c'est très très cool vous pouvez vous
abonner en cliquant ici fait le c'est
très important
vous avez peut-être déjà regardé des
vidéos sans vous abonner donc c'est le
bon moment
et ici vous avez la vidéo de la semaine
dernière et peut-être que par là il ya
une autre vidéo aussi dans le thème de
la magie tient à très bientôt
ciao